Follow following focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is a language that some of
you have probably never heard of,
but it's a fascinating topic and one
that's definitely worth a look.
The topic is catch you up and then catch
you up.
The language is sometimes referred to as
Luna see me,
which means the people's language.
If we include all varieties of catch you
up.
It is by far the most widely spoken
native language in South America with
between eight and 10 million speakers
spread out across Peru,
Bolivia and Ecuador,
as well as northern Argentina and
southern Columbia.
Spanish is now the dominant language and
all of those countries,
but of course that wasn't always the
case.
Even if you haven't heard of Catchoua,
you've most definitely heard of the Inca
civilization whose capital was located
at Cusco in present day Peru and who's
empire was the largest in the Americas
in the pre colonial period,
and as their empire expanded the
language spread to new areas because it
became the general language or the
Lingua Franca of the areas under the
empire's control,
the origin of catch,
what is debated with some people saying
that it originated in the Cusco area and
others saying that it originated in the
central coastal area of Peru.
Throughout the time of Inca rule.
Catch well was not a written language.
Records were only kept in kibbutz.
A system of nodded strings that serve as
symbols or mnemonic reminders of
information keepers are not fully
understood,
but they are not thought to represent
the sound or the structure of catch you
up.
Instead,
they simply provide reminders of
information to be passed down,
orally catch what did not become a
written language until the Spanish
conquest of the Inca empire,
which took place between 1532 and 15
slash 70 to catch what continued to be
spoken as a Lingua Franca.
After the Spanish conquest and the
Catholic church used to catch why in its
efforts to convert people spreading the
language even further.
The oldest written record of catch you
up is a book written in 15,
60 by the missionary Domingo de Santo
Tomas called Grammar or art of the
general language of the Indians of the
royalty of Peru.
After the Tupac Amaru rebellion of 1780,
the colonial power band catch you up
from public use even catch what texts
that were pro colonial or pro Catholic
were banned and the language began to
decline after the Spanish American wars
of independence from Eighteen,
oh,
eight to 18,
33 gets you ahead a brief revival,
but it has gradually lost prestige and
declined in use.
One of the main reasons for the decline
of catch you up is the use of Spanish as
the language of education and of the
media and the use of Spanish as the main
language of national economies and with
economic development comes increased
urbanization.
When people move from their local area
to a major city,
it's necessary to speak Spanish with the
majority of people who don't speak catch
you up.
Spanish is often thought of as the
language of prestige and of economic
opportunity,
so speakers of catch you up or people
whose parents speak catch you up often
see it as something low prestige and to
avoid some ketchup speaking parents,
avoid speaking,
catch you up with their children at home
and instead speak to them in Spanish.
Even in researching this video and then
looking for volunteers to read the catch
with samples,
some people told me that they themselves
don't speak,
catch you up,
but that their friend's parents speak
Quechua or that their uncle or aunt's be
Peru was the first country to make catch
you on official language in 1975 along
with Imr and other native languages in
Bolivia.
It's been an official language along
with 35 other native languages since
2006 in Bolivia.
Each regional government is officially
bilingual,
choosing both Spanish and one of the
other official languages in Ecuador.
Catch has had semi official status since
2009.
Spanish is the main official language,
but catch one shoe are referred to as
official languages for intercultural
relations even though catch what began
to be written after the Spanish conquest
is still mainly a spoken language and it
isn't really written all that much and
there are various different standards of
orthography.
This is partly because catch was spoken
differently in different places.
Catch what is not really a single
language.
Rather it is a series of closely related
groups of dialects and those groups have
dialects that have a high level of
mutual intelligibility,
can be considered languages.
If there were one standard written
language that was widely accepted and
widely used throughout all the different
areas,
then it might be able to be called a
single language because of that unifying
force,
but there is no such standard language
catch what is divided into two major
dialect categories.
Catch will one and catch what to which
are fairly distinct from each other,
but there's a dialect continuum within
each category.
Catch well.
One is spoken in central Peru and to
sometimes referred to as whitewash.
Catch what too,
which is sometimes called [inaudible]
can be further subdivided into three
dialect groups.
There's [inaudible] in northern Peru.
Catch what to be northern catch well
also known as kitchen which has spoken
mainly in Ecuador and southern Columbia
and catch what to see southern catch you
up,
which includes the catch was spoken
around Cusco in Bolivia and in
Argentina.
Southern catch well is the most commonly
spoken and the Cusco dialect is often
seen as the de facto standard variety of
catch.
Well,
even though it really isn't,
the dialects within each of these groups
are largely intelligible and there is
some degree of intelligibility between
the different groups.
The lowest degree of intelligibility is
between casual one and catch what to
even if both varieties are located in
Peru.
The difference between a one and catch.
What [inaudible] seems to have resulted
from a split from catch will the main
differences between them or in
vocabulary and morphology.
There are differences in pronunciation
to,
but there are also pronunciation
differences within each group.
So what is catch like?
Let's look at some of the features of
catch you up focusing on southern catch.
Well,
syntax catch while isn't Sov language
subject,
object,
verb.
Let's take a look at an example
sentence.
This means Maria builds a house word for
word.
It's Maria House object marker,
build,
third person singular.
You can see that the basic order is
subject,
object,
verb.
The subject comes at the beginning of
the sentence when there's an explicit
subject,
but it's possible to have a complete
sentence without the subject at the
beginning,
like lassie,
todd,
who won the end suffix at the end is a
subject suffix,
so it's often not necessary to have a
subject at the beginning.
Agglutination,
one of catch was main features is that
it's highly a gluten itself.
Let's look at an example of a gluten
nation using a noun.